the polar bear has few natural predators
but he has one deadly enemy climate
change the Arctic is the habitat of the
white bear and other endangered species
as well as home to many indigenous
people and vast coveted oil and gas
reserves in coming decades global
warming is likely to dramatically change
the Arctic the Arctic ice cap stretches
over 4 million nautical miles but its
melting fast many of its gas and oil
reserves are yet to be discovered but
they may account for up to twenty five
percent of the world's natural resources
add to that news shipping routes which
could be navigable for half the year or
20 35 and it's easy to see how the
geopolitical importance of the region is
growing international tensions are also
likely to rise and many any peace are
concerned about the presence of the
Russian military for the future we have
to very clearly and strongly stick to
the international law what concerns also
Arctic's because I see that it is the
only way how to avoid the increase of
tensions in the area because of
increasing economic interest and
competition MEP in the environment and
Foreign Affairs Committee has stressed
the need to avoid a military raised in
the Arctic their report recommends a
comprehensive and cooperative approach
to protect the environment and develop
it in sustainable ways nor makers say
this approach is the only way to ensure
the survival of the polar bear and to
mitigate the human impact on a region
that regulates the climate of our planet
as a whole